the title of our closing special invited
talk is energy all right I'm sorry I did
it right the the title is fusion energy
for the future and our speaker dr.
Charles Skinner from the Princeton
plasmic principal Plasma Physics
Laboratory is probably as well placed as
anyone to know if that tagline energy
for the future will always apply to
fusion it's been the standard joke for a
long time dr. Skinner has not only
worked on fusion energy for many years
he has been active in inventing a number
of techniques that have helped to
improve just about all of the
incarnations of fusion reactors from the
original taco mac fusion test reactor to
the national spherical Taurus experiment
reactor that was developed at Princeton
and now to the current iteration of
fusion called ITER the international
effort to build a fusion reactor so dr.
Skinner
is that I'm going to talk up there thank
you for the introduction hope everybody
can hear me so I'm here to talk about
the fusion and as an energy source and
in the slide what you're looking at is
an image of the edge of the Sun which of
course is a fusion reactor it's a plasma
and these loops are coronal loops that
are being formed in magnetic field above
the Sun so the okay so in my talk held
I'll start by describing what is nuclear
fusion and how it relates to a fashion
why it's important to develop nuclear
fusion as a potential solution to all
the issues we've been talking about what
we've been doing to Dayton and what is
the past diffusion electricity so so the
plot on the left can a foot sufficient
infusion on the same on the same graph
this is the only this is the binding
energy released in the nuclear reaction
and fishing you're coming down from the
left from the right hand side down to
iron which is at a minimum here by
splitting nuclei and on the left hand
side you're fusing nuclei together and
coming down the right-hand side of this
potential curve the big difference
between fish and infusion is diffusion
needs really high temperatures seriously
high temperatures this is the reaction
rate of deuterium and tritium as a
function of temperature and you can see
you need about a hundred million degrees
so that is a big difference now let's
look at the reaction in a little more
detail you have a deuterium nucleus and
a tritium nucleus these are forms of
hydrogen with additional neutrons if you
bring them close enough together they
fuse and form helium and a neutron now
to bring them close enough together you
need a very high temperature 100 million
degrees whoops under million degrees
which is in the unit's we use it's
playing kilo electron volts the product
here the ash if you like of the fusion
reaction is helium which is pretty ideal
you could even use it to fill balloons
for your children it's very energetic
33.4 mev and you can use that energy to
heat the plasma so you can he keep this
reaction going this also a neutron that
comes out at 14 mev and this you can use
then to generate steam and produce
energy in the same way as a fission
reactor the fuel is to Tyrion which you
can obtain from water so it's
universally available to every nation
and tritium is actually a mildly
radioactive gas but you can breed it by
putting lycium in in a blanket and use
the neutron and the react with lithium
to produce tritium so as I said this is
a you need a really high temperature to
do this so why why should you know why
should you try well I feel like I'm
preaching to the choir a little bit here
but as we know from the last IPCC report
to keep the global warming below 2
degrees we need to keep the total amount
of carbon that we ever burn for less
than a trillion tons of carbon and past
halfway to that point and the fossil
fuels fossil carbon remaining in the
ground is actually 427 times higher than
what it would take to get after this two
degrees now this kind of may sound
obvious but what can it boggles my mind
is that we're actually subsidizing
people to explore and find more sources
of carbon you know a couple weeks ago we
all paid our taxes well the US
government spends about six billion
dollars in subsidizing oil and gas
exploration and development and global
it's 26 billion per year and that's the
small part then compared to
honey expenditures which are pension
funds may be invested in which
corresponds to 370 billion dollars each
year to find more deposits of carbon
which in the best case we won't use so
it's under a total waste of money or
putting more nails in the coffin of
global warming anyway we've got it we've
got a number of different options to try
to mitigate this one is nuclear fish in
which we heard about today nuclear
fusion [ __ ] our talk the other other
ones on the table a carbon capture and
storage and renewables but renewables
need a large-scale energy storage in
order to provide energy when the sun's
down and it's not blowing the winds not
blowing and really I think we need all
of these things so I don't feel like I'm
competition with with the vision at all
we this is a huge problem and everyone
needs to work on it okay so now what's
special about fusion well like vision
it's a base load power generation
there's no greenhouse gases and fuel is
practically inexhaustible as it's in
water and available to all nations and
it's really difficult to do and and the
advantage of that is if anything happens
that it terminates diffusion reaction
immediately so there's no chance of a
meltdown the inefficient reactor you
have a core reactor core is something
like four years of fuel stored in in the
in the reactor core in fusion you put in
the fuel you need at the moment it's a
little bit like the engine in your car
now you only put the fuel that you need
in order to turn the cylinder at that at
that point so there's very little fuel
there no possibility of a meltdown and
there is a machine called eater that's
under construction in France that i'll
show you more about later but it has
been has gone through an exhaustive
accident analysis where the safety
engineers imagine the worst possible
event and and then this safety system
doesn't breaks down and something
else happens and the wind is blowing
directly to the nearest town and they
concluded there is no significant risk
to the public and in particular unlike
efficient you don't need a public
evacuation plan since the dose of the
site boundary and the in the event of
the worst credible accident is less than
timber receivers so that's a good good
good advantage and second is the there's
no long-lived radioactive waste the node
transuranics and the ashes i mentioned
is helium now the there is a neutron
produced in the dt reaction that will
activate the surrounding material and
but you can select low activation
materials such as a ferritic steel of an
adium and the bottom right plot is
actually a plot of their hazard of light
water reactor and a fusion reactor and
actually a coal-fired power station
which also they emit low levels of
uranium and thorium as a function of
time and you can see the efficient the
fusion reactor over some tens of years
actually goes below the coal-fired power
plant so that's very good in the top
right graph is a plot of the hazard from
the volatile gases both in fusion and
fission infusion its tritium which is
one of the fuel gases in fish in its
iodine-131 which was implicated in the
whole life from Chernobyl and you can
see this there's three orders of
magnitude difference lastly the most
scary aspect to me is proliferation if
you look in the front page of the paper
what's happening in Iran and North Korea
and so on but since there's no fissile
material in a fusion plant you already
have a big advantage there now you can
say well what happens if you know some
foreign power uses a neutrons to create
fissile material well these fusion
facilities are large you can't hide them
down a mine shaft and if you have
inspectors prowling around it if you if
they see any fissile material at all
they know it's
not good because there should be any so
it's easy to detect and if you have a
breakout sennelier where you lock out
the detectors and close the borders it
still takes a couple of months to to
make significant amount of fissile
material and because there's facility is
large and depends on power supplies and
switch yards it's possible to disable it
without any risk of contaminating
contamination okay so to make this
happen is one of the grand challenges of
our era hears a familiar fusion reactor
which is the Sun and in the center of
the Sun there's a temperature of about
10 million degrees this is comparatively
cool from a fusion point of view and
this is a good thing because the
reaction is kind of barely ticking over
we want this son to last another four
billion years it's already lasted four
billion years to produce life on Earth
we wanted to keep going a fusion reactor
has to be about ten times hotter than
that and the power density is also
hotter and it's surrounded by material
it's down here on earth so no question
it's a big challenge so now the fusion
reaction rate is across the product of
the density of the terrarium and tritium
in the reaction cross section which is a
function of temperature and of course it
takes energy in order to create the
plasma and you want to have more energy
coming out from their reaction then it
took you to make the reaction in the
first place and the kind of cut the
number you used to characterize the
insulation factor is the energy
confinement time this is the energy the
plasma thermal energy divided by the
input energy rate and to put all these
together you can get ignition when the
heating from the alpha particle that
helium nucleus that you saw in an
earlier slide balances the plasma losses
and that means this triple product of
density temperature and confinement time
becomes higher than this number so okay
now so how do you confine these ions
obviously you can't let them touch
material walls to NEX
and you rely on the Lorentz force if you
have ions in the magnetic field they are
subject to a force that can twist them
in these gyrations around the field
lines so in this sense now you've got
you can find them in two dimensions
because they're still going to leak out
along the field lines so the trick is is
you take the magnetic field and you turn
it into a torus like this so the field
lines are then continuous and there
aren't any ends that the particles to
leak out now since you've bent it around
the field isn't homogeneous anymore so
there's some other features that make
the particle strip but you can offset
those by twisting the field lines as
they go around the torus it's the same
kind of thing as when you're trying to
put honey on a teaspoon you know and you
can keep done in the spoon to keep the
stop the honey from dripping off if this
is part of the features of a taco mac
and taco mac means that you have a
current that's being induced to go
around the plasma here to give you this
additional field component and this
plasma is then heated by radio frequency
waves by a very energetic neutral
particles that enter the plasma and
collide and he and heat it okay this is
the inside of the largest taco mac in
the world called jet which is in England
what you're looking at is the toroidal
chamber and you see these ribs here
called limiters they are coated with
carbon which is one of the best
materials with be standing high heat
loads this kind of feature on this side
is an RF antenna on the left hand side
you see two arms this is a remote remote
manipulator that can come in to do
maintenance so it's a large large
machine now so how have we been doing
this is a plot of the triple product
that I mentioned earlier the density
temperature and the confinement time as
a function of year
so you can see down in 68 let's say it's
down at this level and has been pretty
much going up very steadily crippling
every one point eight years and this
laterally as a pretty fast rise this
actually is faster than the increase in
computer speed and it's about a factor
of six short of what we need for
ignition so we've been making
substantial progress now the most
recently in in the mid-90s generating
significant fusion power by putting
tritium and deuterium in the inner taco
mac and this is results from both cftr
which is machine at princeton and jet
which is the one that showed you a
couple slides back this is now fusion
power going up to 10 megawatts or to 16
in a pulse and this is then a longer
longer pulse jet these are the people in
the control room including me see there
and this is eddie aikau ski who's now
the director of the office of fusion
energy down in Washington okay so all of
that work led to the design and then the
construction of eater either is the is a
collaboration between seven nations
European Union is taking a line share
because it's being built in France but
also China India Japan Russia South
Korea and the United States which is
basically representing half about half
of the world's population this is the
building site this circular feature here
is the base map for the taco mac and you
can see the walls of the building going
up it's a large site this is a big
enterprise but completion is about 20-23
and it's intended then to generate 500
megawatts of power we call on the last
slide we were like 10 or 16 of 500
seconds a fusion power gain of about ten
and the aim is to demonstrate the
scientific and technical feasibility of
fusion so this is this is being built as
we speak
this is a picture of what's inside the
tokamak building the plasma is this kind
of purple cloud in the middle and it's
surrounded by Diagnostics by heating
beams by all kinds of plumbing by
magnetic fields by cryostats America
magnetic field is super conducting so
it's really a large facility and this is
a bit like well where's waldo if you
look carefully you can see a person
actually there even one up there okay so
while this is being constructed and what
we're doing oh and before I get to that
this is a worldwide effort by these
colored nations are parties to eater and
all these red dots or fusion facilities
all over the world so it is a worldwide
effort okay so what are we doing in the
meantime while eda is being constructed
well as you noticed it's a big facility
and we're looking for ways to make it
make fusion smaller faster and cheaper
into the usual mantra this is what's
called a spherical tokamak at ppl which
is smaller it's not less powerful but it
you can see because of the geometry here
it's a kind of much more skinny column
in the center this has some favorable
properties so that the confinement time
is much higher than it would be in a
conventional aspect ratio machine and
also the amount of magnetic field you
use to confine the plasma is lower these
red lines here the magnetic field coils
and they're kind of pretty skimpy from
normal standards this has been operating
and the similar one in England has been
operating for the last ten years and at
Princeton we're just coming out of an
upgrade phase that will double the
current and heating power and extend the
pulse length by the factor of five so
that should start operating in the next
next few weeks another approach has been
proposed from MIT because magnets are
such an important
element in the fusion reactors this one
is taking advantage of the new
high-temperature superconductors this
one called repco that generates a really
high magnetic field and because the
because of that it can be much more
compact and you see now the man is much
more much larger compared to the size of
the overall machine so there are and
they'll work going on to improve the
concept and improve what will
potentially be a reactor in the future
let me see ok so the remaining
challenges first of all in confining the
plasma in controlling the plasma when
you have a burning plasma some of the
heat is actually coming from the plasma
itself and your and so the external
controls are diminished but you still
need to be able to maintain these really
extreme conditions that you need in
order to make the fusion reaction happen
you also need to do it for a long period
of time you know like months so both of
those are serious challenges the
magnetic field isn't the perfect
insulator some of the plasma leaks out
and affects the materials and you need
to manage that and you need the
materials then not to emit material back
into the plasma like impurities that
would radiate so there's a two-way
street from the plasma affecting the
materials materials affecting the plasma
that needs to be managed and there's
some ideas and how to do that with with
different magnetic field geometries and
even using liquid metals as a plasma
facing component and then after making
the fusion reaction work for a long time
you need to manage the neutrons which
means you need to demonstrate you can
use the neutrons debris tritium and to
extract the power in the neutrons will
damage limiter Wilson you need to
develop materials they little handle
that and of course in the end you want
to make this work 24 hours a day seven
days a week so reliability availability
maintainability inspect ability for such
a
the object is is a big deal ok so the
Europeans now have a roadmap and they
kind of methodically at addressing all
of these issues in a series of steps you
can see the time scale along the bottom
a lot of it will happen with eater this
is a machine in Japan that it's also
being used to look at these operating
issues with long passes there is then
projections for to have a decision to
build a demo in 20-30 this will be after
eater has run deuterium and tritium and
produced a fusion power which will take
some time to build and then a target for
fusion electricity at about 20 50 this
ok so let's go ok so it's so this at
this point you just have one fusion
reactor now the world is growing a
population and people in the developing
countries want electricity too so the
amount of electricity that's needed by
about twenty twelve is projected to be
about twelve terawatts which is about
five times what we what the world
generates now and for fusion could be
part of that you need to start talking
about terra watts and then multiple
gigawatts so the path this is a
hypothetical path so if eater then
produces 500 megawatts in the 2030s then
you have three demo machines which will
produce 100 gigawatts hundred megawatts
electric probably not be available all
the time in 24 this and then you ramp up
you have more and walk more machines
with more power as time goes on finally
now if you look at the big picture for
the over the rest of the century this is
a projection of the world energy demand
this is and this is a log scale here so
you're going from over many orders of
magnitude
typically any new power source you start
with an exponential growth phase and
then you get to a linear phases you just
crank out more units so this is now the
started line is a model by Professor
Cardozo and do it co-authors where you
see the model and you see the solid
lines are they what's actually happening
in fishing and their wind and solar and
fusion would then come into play in the
second half of the century if all goes
well and then shoulder maybe a third of
electric burden about 2100 so it's a
combination it would be part of the
picture including renewables and fishing
okay so to summarize now the need as we
all know for low or no carbon energy is
more urgent than ever a magnetic fusion
offers the potential of relatively clean
safe and abundant energy it's very
technically challenging basically coming
because you're trying to collide two
charged particles together you need to
overcome the cooler unforced in order to
get the strong nuclear force to make
them fuse but we've made a lot of
progress and we're confident that we can
make this work and large-scale energy
use and on the way actually this
enormous amount of science about how to
control and what's going on these
plasmids that we learn so the remaining
the difficulty of the remaining
challenges will determine the economics
of how much how attractive this is
compared to the alternatives but we need
substantial funding you know actually if
I go back a step this is a scale of
dollars if you're talking 12 terawatts
of electric power and reactors typically
cost several dollars or what that's them
tens of trillions of dollars so it's a
in the other world energy is the world's
biggest market and you need money to to
do something significant in it so anyway
you need strong funding and you need
wrong will in order to make this happen
you need the will to persevere in the
face of temporary setbacks and I think
the prospects for making happen depend
on on whether society thinks it really
needs this and whether it's going to be
able to finance it and come up with the
money to do it and we talked earlier
about carbon taxes or carbon fees and it
also depends on the progressing
constraints in in the other alternatives
which if you avoid carbon a carbon
capture and sequestration and storage
for renewables both of which faced
serious technical challenges too so with
that I will close and then leave you
reading list this is a nice introduction
to how fusion power can save the planet
by one of the key people in the field
this is about nuclear proliferation
which is a topic that can oppose me with
with fashion actually this is about the
last plot and why we have solar cells
but not yet nuclear fusion this is a
kind of cautionary tale how societies
choose it's a good book and then you
know related to the issue of leaving the
carbon deposits we know about already in
the ground okay at that point I'll stop
and open for questions
questions for Charles thanks for the
enlightening talk I was just wondering
if you care to compare the tokamak with
the laser fusion hmm i have a number of
backup slides so let's look at the lazy
little too far as there there is an
artist impression of the target at the
National Ignition facility which is a
facility in California and this is an
alternative way to make fusion instead
of having magnetic fields to confine the
plasma you basically have what you might
think of as a very tiny hydrogen bomb it
kind of holds together for long enough
to make enough fusion reactions you hope
now in their case the facility is called
a National Ignition facility which
sounds like they thought they had it in
the bag but it has not so far ignited so
I think once it ignites and then
there'll be no discussion about how it
compares certainly the laser that
they're using is not suitable for power
plant they also have to develop high
repetition high-energy lasers so it's an
alternative way I think the jury's still
out on whether it's going to be a good
power plant yes would it be possible to
do something with fusion in a timely
enough manner to be useful for fighting
global warming you know back in the 90s
though in parallel with the ftir results
I'm the jet results there were a number
of proposals to make reactors similar to
eater but there was a lot of political
in decision at the time just now they
cost money and perception and the
perception was the US has lots of fossil
fuels so why do we need it I I see
Fusion kind of complimenting fashion
because in fishin the amount of uranium
as a fuel that we know about is going to
run out in the second half of the
century so then you have a choice of
either going to breeder reactors or
using fusion so I see it as coming in in
the second half of the century after run
out to uranium for the light water
reactor I was a graduate student in
Princeton the early 80s when they were
talking about being on the verge of
break even point and now 30 some years
later we still on the verge of something
and the closest thing that you talked
about is something that may materialize
in the middle of the 2020s I terrain etc
etc so the point is that we have a
finite amount of money to try to solve
the problem of global warming and I'm
not entirely sure that there are no
showstoppers even once either is
realized in terms of confinement and so
forth so I can't understand why we
should be bothering with Fusion okay
well in the 80s well the 70s let's say
in Princeton there was a PLT Princeton
large tourist was operating and that was
the first machine that achieved high
enough temperatures to be seriously like
several KETV but the first machine that
that produced fusion relevant
temperatures pft ark was being built in
it was constructed in and came online in
the 80s and had some initial
difficulties but they were overcome and
then produced 10 megawatts of fusion
power in the mid-90s so that I think
that's a significant achievement Jade
did the same thing with 16 megawatts you
know the I think if you look at it from
a broader perspective the note
question that we need low and no carbon
source of energy and the three ways I
can see to do it none of them are
certain / carbon capture and storage
it's kind of like a reverse mining thing
you're putting it back in the ground
well you're going to run out of spaces
to put it without causing earthquakes
like you know the moment this reports of
earthquakes in Oklahoma because they're
putting the water from the fracking back
in the ground so that there's a limit to
what you can do there for renewables are
fine you know but you need energy when
the lights when the sun's down and
there's no win and the significant
technical uncertainties in in the kind
of energy storage that you'd need for
just renewables by themselves to take
over so to me it's a big problem maybe
the biggest facing humanity in this
century and there's no of no guaranteed
solutions so we need to do to pursue all
the avenues that we have available to
try to solve it and by the way I think
there has been a lot of progress in
fusion as I showed you with that plot so
I think fusion the biggest factor
slowing fusion down is the lack of
funding I have a plot for that yeah here
so this was produced in 1976 which was
contemporaneous with the oil crisis and
and and that's when the fusion budget
went up this is the this is this black
line here and this was the projection so
what it would take to make fusion energy
and this is this is the maximum effort
this is accelerated aggressive moderate
and this is the constant so the actual
funding has been far less than what
people knew that they would need in
order to get fusion energy working in
Iraq which the access is at billions of
dollars there or something yeah this is
the budget and billions of dollars yes
two thousand twelve dollars
yeah the the in the in the 70s and 80s
us was well leader infusion it started
to eat a project Reagan and Gorbachev is
part of the summit meeting I tell you in
the 90s in spite of the results from the
FBI it's kind of being a little
indecisive and now this more money is
being spent in Japan and Europe on the
fusion in the US quick question for me
and then we'll wrap up so I think about
a year ago Lockheed Martin made a
splashy announcement about kind of
fusion in a bottle or really fusion on
the drop just when I asked if that's
credible or yeah what's the what's the
feeling on that on there ok and ok good
question thank you for asking so this is
this is what was reported in aviation
week by Tom Maguire who's the lead
physicist for this machine and he said
you know obviously they want to make it
smaller cheaper faster same so good ten
times smaller is to keep it on the
physics side it has to work and then
project is in its earlier stages many
key challenges now you feed that into
the Lockheed publicity machine I think
she's lucky they said they could design
a build and test the first reactor in
less than a year ok this was an October
so they've got like five months left ok
I'll leave you to judge this for
yourself
okay been a long and fascinating day
just conclude with a few notes of thanks
just like to thank the speakers in the
panelists one last time for terrific
terrific entertaining day I always like
to thank the audience for hanging in
there for a long day so it was terrific
here I thought it was fascinating
questions and a really energetic session
all the way through and then last I
would like to thank Jared one more time
and then a person who was operating the
backgrounds most of you saw her when you
registered at the lunchtime sherry
gargano who is not here anymore she left
to go home for the weekend but sherry is
our senior administrative assistant at
yce I and I can assure you this event
would not have come off in quite the way
it did without cherries wonderful work
in the background so sherry wherever you
are thanks very much and then since this
was Jared's conception and his execution
all the way through i will give him the
last word so Jared well thank you all so
much for coming just super brief some
good news we have a reception afterwards
it will be in the Yale Law School dining
hall just down the hall and to the left
that'll start at five o'clock so i think
we have a few minutes between now and
then but again thank you all for coming
I thought it was a terrific conversation
we had throughout the day a lot of
important issues discussed and I hope
you all come away from this with a lot
to think about so thanks and then also
turn right and walk down to the hall and
in turn left at the end of the ball yeah
and on top of that an extraordinary
thank you to my course taglio who has
been terrific and putting this event on
and in all things I see ya